as promised we will now start developing
generalizations of the different
calculations that we carried out in the
context of the radar example the first
kind of calculation that we carried out
goes under the name of the
multiplication rule and it goes as
follows our starting point is the
definition of conditional probabilities
the conditional probability of a given
another event B is the probability that
both events have occurred divided by the
probability of the conditioning event we
now take the denominator term and send
it to the other side of this equality to
obtain this relation which we can
interpret as follows the probability
that two events occur is equal to the
probability that the first event occurs
event B in this case times the
conditional probability that the second
event event a occurs given that event B
has occurred now out of the two events a
and B were of course free to choose
which one we call the first event and
which one we call the second event so
the probability of the two events
happening is also equal to an expression
of this form the probability that a
occurs times the conditional probability
that B occurs given that a has occurred
we use this formula in the context of a
tree diagram and we used it to calculate
the probability of a leaf of this tree
by multiplying the probability of taking
this branch the probability that a
occurs times the conditional probability
of taking this branch the probability
that event B also occurs given that
event a has occurred how do we
generalize this calculation consider a
situation in which the experiment has an
additional third stage that has to do
with another event C that may or may not
occur for example if we have arrived
here a and B have both occurred and then
C also occurs then we reach this
particular leaf of the tree where there
could be other scenarios for example it
could be the case that a
not occur then event B occurred and
finally event C did not occur in which
case we end up at this particular leaf
what is the probability of this scenario
happening let us try to do a calculation
similar to the one that we used for the
case of two events however we need to
deal here with three events what should
we do well we look at the intersection
of these three events and think of it as
the intersection of a composite event a
complement intersection B then
intersected with the event C complement
clearly you can form the intersection of
three events by first taking the
intersection of two of them and then
intersecting with the third after we
group things this way we are dealing
with the probability of two events
happening this composite event and this
ordinary event and the probability of
two events happening is equal to the
probability that the first event happens
and then the probability that the second
event happens given that the first one
has happened can we simplify this even
further yes the first term is the
probability of two events happening so
it can be simplified further as the
probability that a complement occurs
times the conditional probability that B
occurs given that a complement has
occurred and then we carry over the last
term exactly the way it is the
conclusion is that we can calculate the
probability of this leaf by multiplying
the probability of the first branch
times the conditional probability of the
second branch given that the first
branch was taken and then finally
multiplied with
the probability of the third branch
which is the probability that C
complement occurs given that a
complement and B have already occurred
in other words we can calculate the
probability of a leaf by just
multiplying the probabilities of the
different branches involved and where we
use conditional probabilities for the
intermediate branches at this point you
can use your imagination to see that
such a formula should also be valid for
the case of more than three events the
probability that the bunch of events all
occur should be the probability of the
first event times a number of factors
each corresponding to a branch in a tree
of this kind in particular the
probability that events a 1 a 2 up to a
n all occur is going to be the
probability that the first event occurs
times a product of conditional
probabilities that the eye's event
occurs given that all the previous
events have already occurred and we
obtain a term of this kind for every
event AI after the first one so this
product ranges from 2 up to n and this
is the most general version of the
multiplication rule and allows you to
calculate the probability of several
events happening by multiplying
probabilities and conditional
probabilities